well guys for weeks now we've been
following the faze clan vs. t food
lawsuit and we've strived not only to
bring you net new information and
important context in the case but report
it in as balanced and neutral away as we
are able we went over the lawsuit we've
went over t poos leaked contract we've
heard from his lawyer and other legal
experts and now it's time to hear faze
clans side of the story
[Music]
you know what [ __ ] intro we
interviewed Lee trink CEO and co-owner
of faze clan to get his side of the tea
foo lawsuit before we get into all the
legal defenses let's start with a
question that I've had since this
lawsuit was made public what exactly is
the status of tee foo on faze clan right
now well look obviously he's not
representing us anymore we consider him
still on faze clan until he's not on
faze clan that's really what does that
mean I don't you know I guess depending
depending on the on the circumstance I
can tell you how that how that looks to
the public but we consider him a part of
faze clan until he's not a part of faze
clan him just taking the logos off his
pages doesn't make him out you'll know
from our previous coverage that the Tipu
lawsuit has two major thrusts to it
number one that faze clan is allegedly
acting illegally as a talent agency
while not having a license to do so in
the state of California and second that
although t foo is listed as an
independent contractor in his original
gamer agreement that he is allegedly
illegally being restricted from pursuing
other opportunities now if you want a
more in-depth discussion on what these
actually mean check out our previous
coverage now let's begin with the first
claim drinks position on the allegation
that faze clan is illegally acting as a
talent agency is that the relevant laws
here which are under the California
talent agencies Act cover artists and
that T foo is in fact a professional
athlete these guys are athletes they're
not actors the talent agency act has
never never protected an athlete it's
done specifically for theatrical actors
and I am sure that if you've got people
on your show and you would say T foo are
you an actor or an athlete what do you
think the answer would be on that
unequivocally if what what Brian is
trying to claim covers this contract it
just simply doesn't cover the contract
it never it never has and and again I
would think I would think the community
doesn't think he's an actor I think he
himself doesn't think he's an actor and
for sure when we signed him he was a pro
gamer they his kind
says gamer agreement it doesn't say
actor worth noting here that the tea
food lawsuit explicitly tries to
categorize him as an artist saying quote
in no uncertain terms these gamers are
artists entertainers and content
creators they perform they act they
direct they edit and they stream and
quote so which is it well the California
Labor Code section 1704 which covers
talent agencies defines artists in the
following way
artists means actors and actresses
rendering services on the legitimate
stage and in production of motion
pictures radio artists musical artists
musical organizations directors of
legitimate stage motion picture and
radio productions musical directors
writers cinematographers composers
lyricist arrangers models and other
artists and persons rendering
professional services in motion picture
theatrical radio television and other
entertainment enterprises end quote now
there is no telling how an actual judge
would interpret these passages but I
feel like a strong argument could be
made that T foo is in fact an artist in
so much as he streams for entertainment
after all isn't that what streaming is
about now too that Lee Trent told me
that Teague was signed as a competitor
as an athlete and just because he does
some vlogging and some other
entertainment projects doesn't take away
from the fact that he is still an
athlete he also told me that his
streaming is essentially thought of as
practice for his competitions the reason
why streaming works for four nights
because you can do it by yourself at any
moment and say all right I'm welcoming
you in to me practicing while I while
I'm preparing to compete what I'll also
say is let's talk about why he signed
with us what was the purpose of it what
was the salary for the salary was for
his professional gaming skills he
doesn't convert to something else
because he has other interests the same
way in the brine LeBron does a lot of
other things right does it make him any
less of an athlete it does it just
doesn't and so all of these things
support his brand building like again go
look at the I shouldn't have to convince
you
he flew himself is telling you what he
is he's a professional athlete now on to
the second major contention of the
lawsuit that T Fu's contract is in
violation of section 16 600 of the
California business and Professions Code
and that he is allegedly illegally being
restrained from pursuing other
employment opportunities after and
during his time with faze clan as an
independent contractor trink told me
that Teague should be considered a
unique talent and therefore wouldn't
fall under the law the same way you and
I would as employees or independent
contractors code 6600 typical
independent contractors it covers that
but you know what it doesn't cover it
doesn't cover uniquely talented
individuals or athletes t foo is a
unique talent the same way as LeBron
James is a unique talent and when LeBron
signs to the Lakers
guess what he can't do he can't play for
any other team so it's another there's
another smoking mirror up he makes a big
showing a lot of saber-rattling it says
oh we're going in front of the
California Labor Commission no problem
we'll be happy to see you in front of
the California Labor Commission because
we know under both of these claims
they're both losers back here I believe
Trank is referring to California Labor
Code section two eight five five which
allows for a person of unique unusual
and extraordinary value to be signed
exclusively for no more than seven years
now I spoke to James Goodman a
california-based attorney who
specializes in labor law about this and
he told me that to 8:55 has been applied
in cases involving actors and notably in
a case featuring 1960s and 70s
basketball star Rick Barry now there are
other possible exceptions to section
16600 of the business and Professions
Code but from my admittedly
surface-level understanding of
California law they are rare and
specific and might not be easily applied
to this case in fact that's kind of the
story with this entire lawsuit
California law and probably law
everywhere else is not very well
equipped to deal with cases of this
nature with cases
fall within eSports and gaming and
streaming and if this lawsuit does make
it to court which it probably won't it
could set the tone for all future legal
action and contract within the realm of
eSports streaming and gaming now other
than those two main points there was a
lot of talk especially early on after
the lawsuit was made public about just
how bad t Foos original gamer a contract
apparently was now drink categorizes it
as a sort of a Wilkie contract something
that t foo was meant to grow out of as
he grew as a competitor rookie
agreements are not great and they're in
brookie agreements get renegotiated all
the time in everything else in sports
music film you name it it's really
common it's only not comedy this is the
first one so everybody's in arms in it
by the time we get to the tenth one it's
not going to be much of a story anymore
and it's gonna be it's gonna be
considered ok you sign a rookie
agreement with terms that are that are
you know that are tough terms and when
you blow up and when you get to be huge
guess what everybody everybody
renegotiates and everybody he comes up
with a new deal because it's better for
everybody now as to the amount of money
that faze clan is entitled to under the
original gamer contract which was a
pretty controversial point when this
whole lawsuit was made public drink
doubles down on the notion that while
Tipu brings a lot to the org by just
being signed with them they have taken
precious little directly from him and
we've already said we haven't taken any
money from you guys this is a guy he's
probably made he's made certainly 1520
million dollars since he's signed with
us right he's personally made money
someone is gonna be somewhere around
that around those numbers yeah and there
have been some other you know other you
know you know benefits I would never
deny that of course of course there is
but as far as actually talk about my
monetary benefit a guy who's made tens
of millions of dollars and we've taken
60 60 grand it's like to be honest I'm
almost embarrassed we've had to defend
the fact that we've only made sixty
thousand dollars from the kid those of
you who have been following this case
really closely may recall that the
lawsuit made some proclamations about
bettering the gaming in
to quote it directly through this action
Tenny that's t fou seeks to ship the
balance of power to the gamers and
content creators / streamers those who
actually create value and drive the
industry as a result of this action
others will hopefully take notice of
what is going on and help to clean up
eSports end quote
drink perhaps unsurprisingly takes a
very different view of the lawsuit and
didn't mince words when it came to what
he thought T Fu's lawyers motivations
were you know look I think that when you
look at this lawsuit overall I think
that any of the claims that are that you
know that that tifa's lawyer makes about
trying to better the industry I think
that that I think it's a farce I think
that what he's trying to do and I think
his goal is to get tea throughout of his
contract by any means necessary I think
that what I really want to make the
point of none of this is about bettering
the industry this is about Brian
Friedman trying to get more press for
himself more clients for himself and I
think people just wants out of his
contract and I think he's he's taking
bad advice from Brian to say do it my
way and I'll get you in our first video
featuring t Fu's lawyer Brian Friedman
he told us that T Fu's team had sent
base clan a proposed contract which they
then gutted and sent back allegedly
making it illegal days later keemstar
released a video with the statement from
phaz that called that very same contract
quote impossible to sign end quote
why is that well Lea trink has a
slightly different version of the story
and here's what he had to say about that
situation what he said was a markup of
our Traven he didn't send a brand-new
agreement so this is this is it this is
with all the red line markup but I'm
gonna I'm gonna read one excerpt that
you'll see that I highlighted for myself
that made this impossible to sign that
yes technically it's words on a on pages
with a signature letter but it's not a
contract because if that's not a
contract that makes sense so here it is
gamer may provide services or otherwise
work for create content for or be
employed by
any eSports team or gaming company
that's it this is the same it's the same
way doesn't he tries to create this
smoking gun moment where he swear he
jumps up and down he says we sent them a
contract dammit see he's not trying to
get out but you know it here if you want
it you want to do a screenshot of that
that's the line right there if you want
to take a look at it that's it
so when where and how is this whole
thing going to actually end forty Fu's
part it seems pretty clear that he just
wants out of his contract and out of
phase drink told me that faze clan would
be willing to deal his contract to
another org as long as they were able to
benefit from that just like a
traditional sports team would trade a
player to another team he wants to go to
another work that's fine but then then
we should get some value of having him
under contract and transferring him in
good faith we're happy to but you know
the reality is all of those times we
tried to you know the many times we
tried it's been in good faith the
problem is I've never had good faith on
the others I've never been met with
actual good faith on the other side from
whether it's Brian running the campaign
or the previous advisors running the
campaign for sure looking back there has
never been a good faith approach to
sitting down with us and coming up with
a real resolution because we tried again
very hard to come up with with creative
solutions when you don't get any
feedback from the other side and so
we're back to the drawing board saying
okay can somebody else guess what maybe
teef who wants let's put that in
agreement but what if T foo wanted to
start his own org and join that as some
people claim on that trink did not have
a definitive answer saying that faze
clan would cross that bridge if and when
they came to it finally the CEO and
co-owner of faze clan told me that since
in his own words faze clan is at the top
of the heap when it comes to gaming orgs
more lawsuits may be on the way but that
the future of faze clan looks brighter
than ever when you are the biggest the
best the most powerful the most famous
the most fans guess what you also have
you got a lot of people coming at you in
every direction I have bolstered myself
that I think that lawsuits are gonna be
something that we're gonna have to just
get comfortable with we continue to
apply new talent we continue to support
your talent we continue to win that's
the story of faze clip you know that's
you know to me we're quickly looking
what we've got going into world cop
nobody else has that you know I don't
know to me if the future is bright as we
can possibly imagine this week thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
it up art Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]